Hey, this is kind of interesting and I think
it's a good opportunity for an important discussion.
MSNBC host Joy and Reid, Joy Reid, I guess
she goes by now.
On Tuesday, she was accused of Islamophobia
over some remarks that she made on the Monday
evening program where she kind of equated
radicalized Trump supporters to, quote, the
way Muslims act.
And, of course, that doesn't sound good.
And she is rightly being criticized.
And I think this was actually a missed opportunity
to bring something to the forefront.
That is a really important discussion to have.
So the setup is that they were having a panel
on her program about President Trump not denouncing
his supporters role in the violence in in
being violent at protests in Kenosha and in
Portland.
And after noting how Trump liked a tweet praising
vigilante Kyle Rittenhouse and cheering pro
Trump Trump demonstrators in Portland.
Reid tried to make a point about the president
radicalizing his base.
And it's sounding like the way Muslims act.
It doesn't sound good and it wasn't good.
Take a look at the video.
It went one thing when leaders, let's say,
in the Muslim world, talk a lot of violent
talk and encourage their supporters to be
willing to commit violence, including on their
own bodies, in order to win against whoever
they decide is the enemy.
We in the U.S. media describe that as they
are radicalizing those people, particularly
in their radicalizing young people.
That's how we talk about the way Muslims act
when you see what Donald Trump is doing.
Is that any different from what we describe
as radicalizing people?
I don't believe so.
So, Joy, Reid is being rightly criticized
here because she's saying, oh, so all Muslims
are radical.
She's using language where she says the most
radical Trump ists are like Muslims generally.
And of course, that couldn't be further from
the truth.
We've got over a million Muslims.
The overwhelming majority, as we all know,
are not radicals and they're not violent.
And all of that stuff.
But there was really an opportunity here to
have an important conversation, the conversation
to be had.
And I would have been with only a slight change
to wording Joy.
Reid would have been able to do it.
The conversation is extremism starts to look
the same.
Any time religious fanaticism or cult like
behavior is at play.
And when you look at right wing Christians
and the most extreme movements within right
wing Christianity, when you look at radical
Islamists, when you look at Trump cultists
with guns, they are all very similar.
The cult like reverence to whatever, sometimes
its God, sometimes it's a religious leader,
sometimes it's a cult leader.
Sometimes it's in the case of Trump, an elected
official.
That is a real consideration.
And in fact, it's part of the conversation
where when we talk about political violence,
you often see it categorized as right wing
violence, including stuff like militias and
sovereign citizens and white nationalists,
eco terrorism like, you know, the small slice
of political violence that would be based
on things like climate defense on the left,
very rare, and then Islamic political violence.
I've made the case for years that if you believe
religion should be the supreme law of the
land and you are willing to go and commit
violence in the name of religion, it doesn't
really matter what religion that is.
That's almost certainly right wing violence.
So I've been saying for a while, radical Islamic
violence is right wing.
And when you look at the precepts and the
beliefs of radical Islamists and compare them
to radical Christians and white nationalists
who are often influenced by Christianity,
they're really almost the same.
Different details internally and they're really
all right wing.
So I get why Joy Reid is being criticized.
She didn't address this the right way.
She simply said this is how Muslims Act, which
sounds like she's saying this is how all Muslims
act.
And it's important to remember that when we
on the left talk about this.
I never say all Republicans x all Trump ists.
Why we don't say all Muslims X, of course.
And the missed opportunity here would be to
say what we are talking about here is that
radicalism all starts to look the same.
We should be able to apply the same language
to it when we talk about Trump, radicals,
Muslim radicals or whoever.
Congresswoman Ellen Omar tweeted about this
saying, quote, Honestly, this kind of casual
Islamophobia is hurtful and dangerous.
We deserve better.
And an apology for the painful moment for
so many Muslims around our country should
be forthcoming.
It is hurtful and it's unproductive, but it
should be OK to talk about how all extremism
starts to look very similar in a way that's
serious and in a way that sober, sober.
So Joy Reid missed an opportunity to say these
radical trumpet's show the same type of radicalization
that we see in all radicals, including radicalized
Muslims, who these radical trumpet's claim
to oppose.
They are more similar, in fact, than they
would have you believe.
That has to be OK to talk about.
I believe that if Joy Reid had couched it
in those terms, it would not have gotten the
backlash that it received.
A radical is a radical.
Doesn't matter if it's a you know, based on
race, color, creed, politics, a radical is
radical and it all starts to look the same.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember to get the daily audio podcast on
Spotify, Stitcher I, iTunes, wherever you
listen to
your podcasts.